الثوره الفرنسيه قدمت مكاسبه لكل اوروبا
والعالم وكانت نموذجا حتى خارج اوروبا ان
تمسكنا بحقوق الانسان راسخ ولكن السياسه
الخارجيه يجب ان تكون براغماتيه وان
تعاملنا فقط مع الدول التي لديها ذات
النظر الى حقوق الانسان لا يكون لدينا
علاقات مع بلدان كثيره في العالم هناك
بلدان حتى داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي نرى ان
ممارستها السياسيه هي محطه جدلا وشك في ما
يتعلق بتطبيق حقوق الانسان اذا هذه مساله
معقده بالنسبه الى سوريا هنا اتذكر جيدا
تلك المرحله علينا ان نعلم ان صحكوزي كانت
لديه التحفظات ذاتها التي كانت لدى
بشار الاسد
ولكن شعرنا
انا بشار الاسد لا يفي بالتزاماته حدث بعض
التشنج بين بشار الاسد وفرنسا وكذلك بين
الاسد وبلدان اخرى مثل دول الخليج كان لدي
ساكوزي مشروع كبير تحت عنوان الاتحاد من
اجل المتوسط من اجل تحقيقه كان عليه ان
يضم اليه كل البلدان المعنيه وتاليا كان
من الصعب استبعاد سوريا عن هذا الاتحاد
حاول ساقوزي اي يعاود الاتصال مع بشار
الاسد لينجز مشروع الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط
بعد ذلك راينا ان هناك بعض الالتزامات
التي لم يتم الايفاء بها لاحقا وبعد
الربيع العربي ايضا راينا كيف تعامل بشار
الاسد مع المعارضه وهنا تدهورت العلاقات
صدرت مواقف فرنسيه معارضه ضد الرئيس
السوري
همم بننطقه كوتيس في وقتنا من الاوقات
واذا اردنا ان نتحدث في هذا الموضوع وهذا
ما نراه اليوم في روسيا هذا الامر يطرح
الكثير من المشكلات بالنسبه الى خذلان
الشعب السوري ساخزي لم ينجح في البدايه مع
بشار الاسد لاجباره على اتخاذ موقف مختلف
اذا ام طالب شعبه ولا اعتقد ان فرنسا كانت
الدوله الوحيده التي حاولت مع الاسد
فالسلطات السعوديه على ما اعتقد حاولت
افهمه ان بعض الامور لا يمكن ان تحدث
وعليه الاستماع الى مطالب الشعب عندما
يكون المرء على راس الدوله
همم ما الذي جعله يعرض عن ذلك لاحقا هل هو
الانسحاب الامريكي الرفض الاميركي للتدخل
رغم الخطوط الحمراء التي حددت
gpskip
لانني كنت وقتها في البرلمان الاوروبي
ومهتمه اكثر بالقضايا الاوروبيه اعتقد انه
حدثت وقتها نقاشات بين دول عند ومنها بين
فرنسا والولايات المتحده لمعرفه ما هو
الموقف الواجب اتخاده في المنطقه السوريه
ولكنها لم تكن فقط محصوره للمنطقه السوريه
لان الازمه السوريه كانت لها تبيعه ابعد
من ذلك واننا نلاحظ اليوم ان القوه العظمى
مهتمه بما يحدث في هذه اللعبه الاقليميه
في هذه النقطه تحديدا اكرر انا لم اكن
وقتها في الحكومه اذا لا يمكنني ان اؤكد
تفاصيل تلك المرحله ولكن اعتقد انه كان
هناك نوع من التقارب في بعض المواقف
وتباين بسيط في بعد الاخر كان هناك توافق
مبدئي على ادانه ممارسات بشار الاسد ولكن
لا احب ان اتكلم عن شيء في وقت لم اكن فيه
في صلب موقع اتخاذ القرار وقتها